record. Okay, so we are recording today's podcast webinar zoom call whatever we're calling
this. We have some questions that we want to go over so hopefully this will be helpful for people.
If you have other questions as we go through this feel free to interrupt and just
scream at me. Alright, so the question that we've had a couple times and we've had somebody
actually email me this question and then we actually had somebody yesterday ask the same question
again is about how do we judge our supplements that were currently taking or buying a supplement
or my friends having a supplement or my daughters taking a supplement. How do I know if it's a good
supplement or maybe that's such a good supplement. So rating different supplements is important.
You know, if you're not a nutritionist you haven't had any education in this background. It's hard
to tell whether something's good or not. So that does become complicated. So even if it says
something great on the label we know for a fact that that doesn't mean that that's really what's
in the product. Matter of fact a couple of years ago there was an independent study that took
I think a Walmart supplement, a GNC supplement, a Walgreens supplement and a Target supplement and
there are all Echinacea which is an herb for immune boosted and they sent it to an independent lab
and all of them came back with almost no Echinacea in it. Now that's really hard to believe how
a supplement company can be so blatantly dishonest but understand this is all driven by capital. It's
all driven by capital. So the companies that I use most of them I've toured their facilities
and I see what they do in testing their product. So I like to use companies that are extremely
anal in perfectionism and go to the extreme about perfection in their products that they'll get a
they'll get a product in bulk because these companies they buy product in bulk and that they will
mix them and put them together and sell them. So they literally get a palette with a ginormous
package of Echinacea ground Echinacea root from some supplier and then a good company will do a lab test
on it and they'll do multiple lab tests with multiple samples to see if it actually has the
constituents that are labeled on it that they purchased and if they if it doesn't it could set back.
That's why sometimes our supplements are on back order because the companies that we use are
extremely anal with their perfectionistic tendencies and they will refuse to sell something that is
less than perfect. So they just they just deny it and it could set back and then it's like okay no
they don't have curcumin for two weeks. So that was the last order of curcuclear that we had. We
are back ordered for like two weeks out there three weeks we had like almost a mess. So that's
happens quite frequently with us but yeah I would rather err on that side than err on giving people
fake stuff. But we're not going to talk about fake stuff here we're going to talk about how you can
look at a label. One person had a question is coral calcium good for you because you'll get a lot
of misinformation out there too. So that's what we're going to try to clarify here misinformation.
So there's a lot of articles out there that coral calcium is the best calcium
to to consume because it comes from sea coral from Okinawa Japan. There was a book written a number
of years ago I think it was back even in the 80s about coral calcium from Okinawa Japan and somehow
that was the key to the to the Okinawa living so long was the coral calcium that they that they
ate. That became a huge hit and a huge topic and somebody built a nutrition empire of that and made
millions and unfortunately it's all misinformation. So you're just getting my opinion here. So there may be
somebody who sells coral calcium that's going to differ completely with my opinion but I'm going to
share you here with you my opinion and why I have that opinion. So coral calcium is from coral.
It's if you break it down and you look at the back of this it is calcium carbonate. Now I'm not
picking on this company I just pulled this label this picture off the internet today when I put this
presentation together or yesterday. So I'm not picking on this company but they are exploiting a trend
that's based upon the theory that coral calcium is so good for you. So coral calcium is calcium
carbonate. Calcium carbonate is limestone that's what coral is made of is limestone. So limestone is
not the type of calcium that we're supposed to consume. So I'm going to give you a lot of information
of this little presentation here but it all boils down to one sentence if you could remember this.
If you could eat your food as closely to the way that God created it for us to eat then you're always
you're going to error the right side. We are not supposed to eat dirt. That's what that's where you'll
find calcium carbonate. We live in Minnesota. There's a lot of calcium carbonate in the soil around
here there's a lot of limestone. So we're not supposed to consume limestone. Hey if I want to
alkalize by garden because I'm testing the soil and it's too acidic I may put limestone on my garden.
That limestone is a good source of calcium for my plants not for me. So it's a good source of calcium
for my plants. I don't know what happened to my screen could you see that? That's really weird.
Is it something you guys did? Somebody had the color botanon. So that's what choral calcium is.
What's on every slide? That's really weird. I don't know if you guys can see that red.
Can you see that? That is really weird. So I've never seen that before. So we'll keep going.
It's you know it's somebody from the choral calcium foundation that's tried to.
So calcium carbonate is in the soil. Plants take calcium carbonate and then
plants convert it to calcium lactate and calcium glycinate and then we eat plants.
So if you want to eat, if you want to take minerals like oh my gosh I need to take calcium because I
have bone loss. If that was your thought process and we could talk about whether a person with
bone loss should take calcium at another time. But if my choice was to take calcium I want to take
a calcium supplement that is as close to the way that I would get it in a food. So that I would
either take a food-based calcium lactate which there's companies that make that standard
processes one company that makes calcium lactate or I would take a calcium that has a double bond
to a glycine. It is like how am I going to know that? Well this next slide goes over that.
So here's choral calcium. Look at its elemental calcium. It's actually calcium carbonate.
There's no way that you should consume this. I'm going to stop the screen share and start the
screen share again just to see if that changes that color out there, okay? Yeah. I don't know what that
was about. So this is what you'd see at a back of a label of a supplement that you shouldn't eat.
So this is choral calcium. This is not the back of the label of that supplement that picture here.
So I'm not picking on that specific one. And then this has vitamin A is retinal pulmitate,
pulmitate. That's not a great source of vitamin A. This is vitamin C just as scorpic acid. We'll talk
about that. And vitamin E as D alpha to cofferal. We'll talk about that. And then the minerals are as
oxides as oxides as oxides. That's a really, really poor source of mineral right there. Nobody should
be consuming zinc oxide. So not a good supplement. And I just stole this picture off the internet too.
So I have no idea what product that this belonged to. But this is a really poor supplement there.
Well, how do I do? Well, the calcium is not as a double bonded glycine. I'll show you how you'd see
that a good label in a second. It's as elemental calcium or it should be listed as calcium carbonate.
And these are as oxide forms of minerals. So it already gives me hints that I don't want to take
this supplement. Here's another picture of a supplement. This is a multiple. And it has vitamin A
as retinal pulmitate. And then some as beta carotene, that's a better form of vitamin A right there.
Let's go down. Here's the D alpha to cofferal again. We'll talk about that in a little bit.
And then how you could tell on the vitamin Bs is they'll have a very specific amount of vitamin B.
This is more, this is more difficult to tell. But when you see a vitamin B that has 50 milligrams,
50 milligrams, 50 milligrams, 50 milligrams, then you know it's a synthetic B.
But this is the kicker for this supplement right here. So anytime you look at a multi supplement
and you look, you could tell if it's a good multi or a bad multi partly by going down and looking at
the form of folate they use and the form of B12 they use in a multi. The folate used in this multi
is folic acid. Folic acid if you've watched any of my genetic videos is synthetic folate.
Folate is a B vitamin that's found in foliage. Green leafy vegetables have folate. So folate is
necessary to make methyl tetrahydrofolate through the met through the folate pathway. And that goes
into four methyl groups that turn genes on and off. And it's very important supplement. What happened
was that at the turn of the last century, not very many Americans, especially in inner cities like New
York and things like that, we're eating a lot of foliage because it wasn't readily available.
So the staple diet in the middle of large cities was mainly potatoes that could be stored at
grains, flour, wheat, bread, things like that, and meat. So that was the typical diet. They
weren't eating hardly any foliage. So they were not getting the only source of folate from them
wasn't foliage because they weren't eating it. But there's also folate in the outer husk of wheat.
So if you ate whole wheat bread, you'd get some folate. But then in the Advent, the early 1900s,
they came out with a new way to store flour because if we just grind wheat and store it,
the outer husk has all the nutrients in it. It also has some oil in it. Wheat your oil is in that
outer husk. Well, the oil makes the flour spoil quicker. So it had a short shelf life.
But however, the wonderful companies that control our country found out that if we take the outer husk
off the wheat, then it has a very long shelf life. So it helps grocers be able to store more and it
doesn't go bad so they don't have waste. And it makes very fluffy bread. So everybody loved it.
So the advent of white flour, people lost folate in their diet, especially in inner cities. So they
weren't getting folate in their diet. It also exposed the gluten in the wheat. So people were
starting to develop gluten-sensitivities but had no idea at that time. So they lost all the nutrients
and they were starting to develop gluten problems and developing gut problems. And now they were
having folate deficiencies. And now, mothers were giving birth to babies with neural tube defects,
spite of bifinus and such. So then the research went back to what's causing all these neural tube
defects. And they found out that it was a deficiency in folate. So then in their wise wisdom,
discovered that we could create folate in the laboratory and we'll call it folic acid and we'll
patent it. Well said somebody, probably, it's not the same as folate that's in nature. Well of course
it's not the same said the boss. It's called we're going to call it folic acid so we can patent it,
we can sell it, we can fortify all the white flour with folic acid and sure enough it did prevent
neural tube defects because it was similar enough to folate. The problem is it's not folate and you
can't make things in the laboratory that are going to work the same way as God created them. So folic acid
has now caused all sorts of problems. It causes defects in our genes in the folate pathway. So now we have
our current generation and maybe you have metal tetrahedral folate reductase G defects caused by
folic acid supplemented as a synthetic folate in our supplements like this one right here.
And in our foods like if you go back and look at your back of your weedies box, it has folic acid in it.
So we took out the supplements, we took out the good nutrients from the food and we supplement
crappy stuff back that actually caused more problems than good. So that is what folic acid is, folic acid
is synthetic folate. So it's listed as folate as folic acid. So it's folic acid in this product which
there be hundreds of other nutritionists believe that folic acid should be literally outlawed as a
poison. And it's not because it's cheap and we could put it in a supplement. So I understand if
you and I were going to open up a supplement company, okay, we're going to start a supplement company.
And so we're going to buy these products, all these different things we buy them in bulk from
different suppliers. Okay, we can have beta-carotene, you want the retinal pulmitate that costs $450
a pound load or do you want beta-carotene that costs $600 a pound load. We'll pick that one. It's
cheaper. Okay, do you want just the scorpic acid as vitamin C because technically, legally, that's
what vitamin C is. No, we want the whole food vitamin C is found in nature. Oh, well, scorpic acid's
only $300 a pound load, the whole food vitamin C, that's going to be $1400 a pound load. Okay,
everyone, we'll just take this one. And we go down the list this way and you formulate a supplement
with not a nutritionist, but with, you know, an economist trying to make money for my company. And we
pick crap, sorry, like this stuff. And we put a little twist on it, you know, so that we could market it.
And we hire a good marketing company. And we sell a lot of supplements. No different than McDonald's
theories that we don't have to have the best hamburger. We just have to have the best marketing.
And McDonald's has done quite well with that belief system. And so do a lot of supplement companies
like this one. We could point out a bunch of other stuff that's in here that it's not a good form of
product. A methylchymolamine, that's a, that's a better form of B12, but it also depends on the dosage.
Well, it's not a high dosage. So if cyanochymolamine wasn't done this list, and this wasn't done this
list and some of these other things that were done this list, I would say it's not necessarily a bad
supplement. Because methylchymolamine is a good form of B12, but you can't have a very high dose if
you have defects on your biopterate pathway, but that's another story. Cyanochymolamine is a synthetic
B12 that nobody should be consuming. So these are just little hints. So if you know some of these,
like, oh, don't eat anything with folic acid in it. Okay. So you won't have to know anything
else I said. But if you could just know that, you'd go, this is the supplement that my daughter's
taking. Throw this in the trash. You should not even give it to the dog. Okay. Still with me?
Okay. So a hint about minerals. So one of the things that you look at that's quick tell for good
supplement, bad supplement is folate, it'd be 12. Another hint is the minerals. So whatever I said
on this slide, if it's calcium carbonate or an elemental calcium or an oxide, we don't necessarily
want to use that. Here's a supplement that we use and you'll see it says bisglycerate. So all the
minerals are keylated with a glycine and the bismeeds, it's a double bond to a glycine. That's how
it would be found in nature. So that double bond, so chemistry here, potassium, double bond to glycine,
that's how you get it across the gut wall. So that is really important. Now this company right here,
this is the company we use, PHP for our minerals here, they don't make the mineral. So you'll see in
so many companies, this tracks right here, tracks is the supplier who supplies a really good mineral
to supplement companies. They don't sell directly to the public, they don't bottle their
own. This is a company that understands physiology and they said, we're going to create the best mineral
on the market and that's their company, right? And then they sell it to supplement companies to make
their own supplements on it. So you see something that says tracks like that, you know, it's a good
mineral but they only do minerals, tracks does. So but then you know, it's a good mineral. So that's
how you could tell these little hints on good supplement, bad supplement. Still with me, I told you back
here that vitamin E here, one of the ways you could tell it's bad is if it's, if partly it depends
on what you're trying to do with the vitamin E, but vitamin E and vitamin C, let's talk about that
for a second. So vitamin C, when it was first discovered, it was back in the 1920sish or 30sish,
and the level of microscopy they had, the strength of their microscopes was such that they could only see
the outer shell of the molecule. And with vitamin C and vitamin E, this is true. So the discoverer
of vitamin C saw the outer shell and he called it a squirmic acid. And he won a Nobel prize
for discovering vitamin C. Two years later, he discovered since the microscopes improved in that time
that, oh my gosh, that's not vitamin C. Same thing happened with vitamin E, that's only the outer shell
there's a whole inner part of the vitamin C molecule. So we went back to the board of drugs
who was naming and defining these nutrients. And they said, oh sorry, we already have it in the
records, this happened with E and C, that a squirmic acid is vitamin C. Now, if you want to say there's
more to it, that's fine, but in the records, that's what vitamin C is. So legally, a squirmic acid
is vitamin C. But vitamin C found in nature is not a squirmic acid. That's like saying,
the shell of the peanut is the peanut. No, because that's what we found first, it's the shell of
the peanut. Now, the shell of the peanut might have some benefits to it, but it's not the peanut,
right? The inner parts, the peanut, but no, it's the shell of the peanut. So we're going to put
peanut shells in our supplement, let's say if peanuts were a nutrient and we're going to be able
to call it vitamin P for peanuts, but no, wait, we're not getting any of the peanut butter. That's
what we really want. Well, sorry, legally, it's the vitamin C is the squirmic acid. So literally,
with vitamin C, a squirmic acid here, all you're getting is the outer shell of the vitamin C found
in nature. That's why I don't prescribe vitamin C very often because you need a whole food
vitamin C. You want it's always best to get your nutrients from food itself. And then a supplement
itself is supposed to be just that a supplement to your food. So that's why when somebody says,
hey, I want a multiple vitamin. I just want a multiple vitamin. I say, well, then by green's first
or something, you can start taking that because that's going to be your best multiple. You're not going
to find a multiple vitamin that's a whole food very easily. Vitamin E, the same thing. You're going to
picture in that vitamin E family is is forward by the inner part of the total triadoles. And you have
four pieces of the total triadole, alpha beta gamma delta, total triadole. The outer part, which was
first discovered, has four outer shells that are called the tocofferoles alpha beta gamma delta to
cofferol. Most vitamin E supplements, most supplements that have that are multiples simply throw in
alpha to cofferol. It's really easy to synthesize in a laboratory. We can make a match of it for
fairly cheap and we can sell it on the market for fairly cheap to companies who don't really give a
rip about the patients who are going to swallow it. And they'll put it in as, oh, yeah, we have vitamin E
right here. 60, I use a vitamin E. Well, what is it? It's alpha to cofferol. It's just this. Excuse me,
you do not have vitamin E. You have the outer shell of eight components of the vitamin E molecule found
in nature. Matter of fact, I just told my staff this morning because we're just mentioning this.
And I said there was a study done about three, four or five years ago because vitamin E is really good
for your heart, but guess which portion of vitamin E is really good for your heart. It's actually the
delta toco, total triadol. That's really good for your vessels. But they did a study a few years ago.
I think to disprove nutrients and they tested vitamin E for your heart and it got published that
vitamin E does not help people with heart disease. And guess what they used? Alpha to cofferol. They
used the outer shell. This doesn't even help your heart. Of course, it wasn't going to test out
prox perfect. Wasn't going to test out correct that it helps your heart. And of course, I got published
and it was noted on CNN news that vitamin E was just followed in a study from blah, blah, blah,
that it does not help your heart. So all these people telling that vitamin E helps your heart wasn't
even true. So it gets discouraging, you know, if you don't read the study. I think the backside of the
garage would probably single would be fine. Okay. Sorry about that, but so, um, yeah. And just double
the one this one right up here and that one over there. Yeah, I think that sounds good.
Okay. Sorry about that. So, uh, that's what we're looking at with all the supplements are very similar
to that. And and it gets very discouraging for you as a patient or as a consumer, you're going to
like, Oh, great. Oh, how am I supposed to know these things? I don't know this stuff. I'm not going to
learn all this stuff. Um, that's why just learning some of these hints could be helpful. So if all you
learned is you look at folate, what's the form of folate? Because it'll always, if it just says
folate here and then look down at the bottom if it says folate as folate or a folate as methyl tetra
hydrofolate, then you know, Hey, they cared. But if it says folate as folic acid, then you go, Hey,
whoever formulated this did not give a rip about the folate that's in there. They put folic acid. Then
I don't need to look any further across this supplement off by list. Follow me. So look for those hints.
It's B12 and it's cyanocamolamine. I'm not looking any further. It's vitamin E as only alpha to
cofral. I'm not looking any further. Now, the only thing that I would say that's the caveat of that
is that if it's a specific nutrient that you're trying to drive only one piece in that pathway,
I have a supplement called called deltinal that only has the delta cocoa tree in all because we're
trying to help the vessels. So we use that for people that have vascular problems, vascular disease
and heart disease. We're not using it for the things that the cofral are good for, which are the skin,
we're using it for the vessel. Understand? So if we're trying to drive a certain pathway, that's a
different story. But when you look at a multiple and they put in these fractional supplements that
are all synthetic, that's bad news. That's not good. They don't care. So hopefully that clears up
a little bit and understanding it doesn't cause more confusion. But if you look at those little
pieces that can be helpful to tell you whether the supplement company, whoever's, whoever put it together
really cares or not. So I know I'm going to open it up here so that I'm going to unmute everybody.
So if you guys have questions, you can speak in any questions right now. Yeah. Yes?
Okay, I'm going to mute everybody again. Okay, essential oils in the rife. So another question
is, can I use essential oils with the rife machine? The answer is yes. There is an essential oil
folder on the rife. So if you look on the rife, go back to the home screen, go to open home, go back
to the home screen. There's a folder with all the essential oils in it. So understand essential
oils work on frequencies. That's how they work. So essential oils are frequencies and we have the
frequencies in your rife machine of all most of the essential oils through the young living brand
essential oils. So you can run those frequencies. They're only like three to nine minutes. You can
run those frequencies in place of in lieu of essential oil itself or you can put the essential oil on
and then run that program and accentuate the value of the essential oil. So then therefore,
you can actually use a little bit less essential oil. So it can be very beneficial. So use those
by only caveat with essential oils is don't use too much of them. They're very powerful and they
can be hard on your liver if they're absorbed. So be careful. I've had patients come in that
had essential oil toxicity. What I determined is essential oil toxicity and they got better when
I took them off their essential oils. So the essential oils are very close to pharmaceuticals.
They're very concentrated herbs. So be careful with them. They can be hard on your liver. So
I don't my rule is two to three a day. That's it. And be careful too much of anything. Remember,
too much of a good thing is a bad thing. Too much of a good thing is a bad thing. But use the essential
oil programs. That's much safer. You're never going to have liver overload or liver toxicity
with the program itself. How do I know if I'm eliminating my toxins? Okay, I'm starting to
doing chelation. I'm doing detox. How do I know I got rid of all my toxins? That is a good question.
So first of all, theoretically we go, okay, I have mercury toxicity. So I do a mercury detox
with my mercury toxicity is gone. And I got rid of all my mercury. That's theoretical
dreaming. You're never going to get rid of all your toxins number one. Well, I understand that. But
how I can how I know that I get rid get my toxic load down that it is less of a problem.
The only way to know that is to do some testing. So kinesiology testing will help us understand
that. So if you come back and I test you again, I can test you where we're at with that toxic load.
There's other toxic load testing that can be done too. So we could look at stool sample testing.
There's herodellesis testing that I'm not a big fan of. There's urinary testing that I'm not
that's much more accurate. But I'm not a fan of because you have to overload on a key later in
order to measure the urine spill the spill of the heavy metal in the urine. So the safest is
kinesiology tested by opinion. But the truth is you have to realize that you are always
toxifying yourself. So even if, okay, I cleaned up my diet, I'm not eating any pesticides because I
mean all organic food now. Well, first of all, does organic food have pesticides in it? Well,
no, they're not sprayed pesticides on my organic food. Well, that's true. But there's crossover.
So I'll guarantee if we did a chemical analysis of all of our organic food in the grocery store,
we would find a some pesticides. So there is some even when we're trying to do everything
positively right, we're still going to be exposed to foodborne chemicals. Secondly, we're exposed
to toxins everywhere. We breathe them in. So the fastest way to get a poison in somebody's body
is to inject it into their bloodstream. The second fastest way to get a poison in someone's body is
to breathe it in. So when I breathe in a toxin like exhaust, I breathing that in that is crossing over
my alveolar spaces and my lungs going right directly into my bloodstream. It doesn't go through
digestion like something in my food does. It goes right into my bloodstream. So that is a huge
source of toxicity that is really hard to get around. You know, you're good to be exposed to it.
So it is leaching from your carpeting. It is leaching from your sheet rock. It is leaching from
it's just everywhere. Okay, we're not talking about pesticides. You're talking about
irrigated compounds. So we're all exposed to toxins. And as long as we are toxifying ourselves
at a greater rate than our body's ability to rid ourselves of those toxins, we are becoming
more toxic. So do we ever stop detoxing? In a sense, we might take a break from using a
support of that pathway. We might take a break from using milk thistle for a couple of days or
something like that. But in reality, your body is never stopping detoxing. So you're always detoxing
or you're going to die. So that's a constant process. But how do you know you're winning the
battle? Or you're losing the battle is the only way to do it is to test. You can say, well,
you know, I feel better. I'm not as bloated. My liver doesn't hurt anymore. Different things like that
can give you hints to that. But the only perfect way to know is to go back to the test that found
in the first place. So to do that is a wise thing sometimes. So hopefully that answers that question.
Okay, I'm going to open up the mute again. And so I'm guessing she got dropped off. Yeah,
anybody have any questions? So you get everybody. Anyway, she's here and she's been with me for eight years.
Okay, so I think I muted the right person there. So anybody have questions? Oh, wow,
guys are good. By the way, remember, you could email the questions, email it to the
clinic, email address. And I saved those questions. And we covered them. I think I covered
everybody's question that they said did. And patients that talked to me today. So this will be
recorded. It'll be up on Facebook within the next hour or so. And I appreciate everybody. And
um, we will talk very soon again. Thanks, Bunch.